President Trump is raising some eyebrows
tonight with a move to essentially
reverse course on a tough set of
penalties against a major Chinese
business some see it as a step to ease
trade tensions other regard the move as
a potential threat to US national
security late this afternoon we received
news of a different sort concerning the
health of the first lady chief White
House correspondent John Roberts leads
us off tonight with that could even jump
right good evening first thing we can
tell you is the first lady is okay she
under what a catherization procedure
earlier today to treat a non
life-threatening condition in one of her
kidneys the White House though kept it
very hush-hush until she was out of the
Oh are in a statement the first lady's
office said Melania Trump underwent an
embolization procedure to treat a benign
kidney condition the procedure was
successful and there were no
complications mrs. Trump is at Walter
Reed National Military Medical Center
and will likely remain there for the
duration of the week the White House
would not say what the condition is but
embolization is typically used to treat
tumors in the kidney a thin catheter
deposits material in the renal artery
which cuts off blood flow to the tumor
if it has benign the tumor shrinks and
disappears while president Trump did not
travel with the first lady to Walter
Reed this morning late this afternoon he
traveled up to visit her president Trump
also headed a high on a sensitive trade
issue with China US sanctions against
Chinese telecom giant ZTE the president
tweeting this afternoon ZTE the large
Chinese phone company buys a big
percentage of individual parts from US
companies this is also reflective of the
larger trade deal we are negotiating
with China and my personal relationship
with President Xi it was a rather
stunning turn for a president who has
railed against China stealing American
jobs ZTE had been punished for violating
US sanctions against Iran in North Korea
the heads of six major intelligence
agencies worried that ZTE devices could
be used to spy on Americans raise your
hand if you would recommend that private
American citizens use Huawei or ZTE
products or services none of you again
are raising your hand thank you for that
but with Chinese officials coming to DC
later this week for trade talks and
press
she Jinping's helped with North Korea
still a crucial part of the diplomatic
calculation president Trump felt it
necessary to dial back on ZTE obviously
this is part of a very complex
relationship between the United States
and China that involves economic issues
national security issues and the like
and it's an issue of high concern for
China that's been raised with the u.s.
with the US government and with our
administration at various levels but the
move brought a sharp response from the
Senate Minority Leader what happened to
America first president Trump's latest
about-face on trade policy won't make
America great again it will make China
great again the backpedal on ZTE keeps
the way clear for China's continued
assistance on North Korea China also
pleased that the u.s. appears poised to
offer North Korea's security assurances
if it just Mantle's its nuclear program
we will have to provide security
assurances to be sure this has been the
trade-off that has been pending for 25
years no president has ever put America
in a position where the North Korean
leadership thought that this was truly
possible that the Americans would
actually do this would lead to the place
where America was no longer held at risk
by the North Korean regime that's the
objectives White House sources tell Fox
News late this afternoon that the
president really wanted to be there when
the first lady travel up the Walter Reed
military Medical Center for her
procedure this morning but if he had
accompanied her he would have had to
bring the White House press pool with
him the president and the White House
wanted to keep it on the down-low so
that's Brett why he waited until this
afternoon to visit her John Roberts live
in the North Lawn John thanks